correspondent John Sparks traveled with
the Ukrainian military to the front line
on the outskirts of kharkiv and sent
this report to warning it does include
video of dead bodies
the most desirable homes in the city of
harkiv are located within its northern
suburbs
but no one comes here now
unless you man a checkpoint or carry a
weapon
or drive a t-72 tank
on the outskirts of the country's second
largest city the ukrainians and the
Russians take pot shots in the woods
as the Ukrainian Army awaits the enemy's
next move
still inside the city
but it's a war zone it's a Battlefield
tanks and heavy armaments
just about everywhere
we were given access to this Suburban
Frontier and taken to a children's camp
in the trees
with mock turrets and cabins and areas
to play
um
shells have pierced the grounds and a
rocket hit the door
our guide did not want to show his face
it's actually punched at the door around
here the rocket
inserted itself through the metal frame
nearby we found a soldier called doc
he'd been planting landmines when the
shells came in what did you see what did
you experience
oh for the walls for me please
yes
going we've got to go in a few minutes
later we had to use his shelter
grad Rockets incoming
the signs of War are all around with the
remnants of a Russian column littering
the trees
it's a sign of what the Ukrainian Army
is able to achieve
in the suburbs of harkiv the Russian
Advance has ground to a halt
and in a gruesome display of grit and
intent we were taken to see the bodies
of five dead Russian servicemen
the ukrainians had arranged them in the
shape of a zed the identifying Mark
placed on Russian military vehicles our
commanders told Russians that
you should
take back
this borders and they tell that
they don't need it
a Ukrainian Captain claiming the
Russians have refused to repatriate the
bodies
the battle may have stalled but it
certainly isn't over everyone in this
city is sure of that
so they prepare themselves for the
seemingly inevitable regardless of the
personal cost John Sparks Sky News in
hark Eve